René Paul savarier est en face de vous
je peux vous appeler monsieur retraite
vous êtes sénateur à l'air de la Marne
monsieur retraite du Sénat voilà non non
pas encore et vous avez choisi
effectivement de d'aborder ce débat je
vous remercie de l'avoir accepté
d'ailleurs tous les deux sur ce sujet
qui va beaucoup occuper le Parlement
dans quelques semaines et qui va être
très important aussi pour le
gouvernement vous avez vous-même je
crois été l'auteur d'un amendement ou
sinon qui porte là je les gars la 64 ans
voilà pour être précise monsieur Savary
c'est à VOUS bah écoutez oui c'est un
sujet qui paraît important je crois que
c'est incontestable non seulement pour
le gouvernement mais pour l'ensemble des
Français simplement la situation on la
connaît quand même par rapport aux
autres pays on part à un âge beaucoup
plus avancé que nos voisins européens on
a un nombre de cotisants par rapport au
nombre de retraités qui est en train de
se dégrader et il sera un moment
important de prendre des mesures et si
on prend pas les mesures tout de suite
elles seront d'autant plus brutales
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
poussons le gouvernement en tout cas la
majorité sénatoriale dont je fais partie
apprend le ses responsabilités en
partant sur un certain nombre de de
principes que sûrement vous partagez
pour certains notamment à faire
confiance aux partenaires sociaux et la
discussion elle doit pas être sur un
coin de table pendant deux trois mois
elle doit s'établir au moins sur un an
avec un principe également que si on
prend pas tout de suite les mesures les
réformes feront qu'on travaille qu'on
travaillera encore plus longtemps à plus
de 65 ans nous on préfère que l'âge soit
ramené à 64 plutôt que 65 et puis on
veut surtout affirmer que le système de
répartition c'est un système qui par
définition dans son financement ne peut
pas être équilibré par la dette donc il
faut prendre des mesures d'équilibre à
travers cette réforme d'autant plus
qu'il y a un certain nombre de mesures
de solidarité qui doivent être
accompagnants toutes ces dispositifs et
qu'il faut bien trouver les financements
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
proposé des mesures paramétriques et
d'ajustement notamment de l'âge avec un
âge de départ de l'âge légal à 64 ans au
lieu de 62 et en accélérant la réforme
Touraine que vous connaissez bien et qui
s'appliquera à partir de 1967 au lieu de
la génération pour commencer
ça pour qu'on voit ce que l'on peut
partager et ma question quelle est la
position actuellement que vous avez par
rapport à cela puisque vous avez au fil
du temps refuser le décalage de l'âge
tout en acceptant réforme tout rêve la
durée plus longue des cotisations alors
il y a eu effectivement c'est le seul
quinquennat celui qui vient de s'achever
qui n'a pas fait de réforme des
retraites puisque président Sarkozy en
avait fait une lui il avait à la fois
augmenté l'âge de départ à la retraite
et la durée de cotisation ensuite il y a
eu en 2013 2014 la réforme Touraine qui
a augmenté la durée de cotisations avec
un ajustement sur les cotisations et
puis le précédent où il n'y a rien eu du
tout bon moi je suis contre partir sur
une réforme qui fixe l'âge parce que si
vous commencez à travailler très tôt
vous avez vos annuités vous n'avez pas
encore atteint l'âge et vous commencez
par rapport à d'autres si vous commencez
à travailler très tôt c'est qu'en
général vous n'avez pas eu des études
prolongées et souvent s'aperçoit que ce
sont aussi les salaires qui sont les
moins élevés donc moi je suis contre
cette cette question cette question sur
l'âge là où je vous rejoins c'est que je
pense pas que équilibrer un système des
retraites avec la dette soit une bonne
chose mais quand je regarde alors pareil
quand je regarde les équilibres
effectivement 4 milliards 8 de déficit
du régime général en 2012 la réforme
Touraine permet d'amener le système à
l'équilibre
en
2016-2017
sur le régime régénéral
augmentation des cotisations c'est pas
la réforme
la durée de cotisation
des cotisations en trois tiers un tiers
pays par l'État un tiers par les
employeurs un tiers par les salariés et
donc régime à l'équilibre qui est devenu
déficitaire en 2019 au moment où le
gouvernement a dit je fais des
exonérations de cotisations sur les
heures supplémentaires c'est pas ça qui
a déséquilibré il y a aussi le rapport
de ce qui partent en retraite par
rapport en 2019 c'est ce qu'il y a des
équilibré c'est un choix politique qui a
déséquilibré le régime général des
retraites donc la question qui se pose
pour nous aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que
sur les projections qu'on regarde du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites il a
refait huit scénarios dont 4 serait
déficitaires 8 ça dépend des hypothèses
qu'on prend sur le taux de chômage etc
etc mais moi je pense que s'il y a un
vrai débat sur les retraites plutôt que
demander de dire on va passer à 65 ans
moi je suis contre ou à 74 de dire aux
Français est-ce que vous préférez passer
à 64 ans ou est-ce que vous payez vous
préférez payer puisque c'est ça le
montant entre 11 et 22 euros de plus par
mois sur les cotisations qui peuvent
être aussi prises en charge par les
employeurs ça ça peut être un vrai débat
parce que je suis pas sûr que ce soit
suffisant quand même ça serait un vrai
débat plutôt que de dire c'est tout tout
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième sujet sur la durée de
cotisation sur ce sujet peut-être la
difficulté c'est une différence parce
que la durée de cotisation qui augmente
c'est inéluctable de toute façon la
réforme va faire que on va en arriver là
simplement sur le plan de de du poids
budgétaire que cela entraîne c'est c'est
minime si vous décalez pas l'âge
pourquoi vous avez 20 ans vous avez 43
annuités ce que propose ça fait 63 ans
si l'âge légal est mis à 64 ans il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui vont dire à ce
moment-là si je peux partir si vous
décalez pas l'âge légal ils partent et
ils n'ont pas forcément puisque là s'il
y a une reste à 62 ans ils n'ont pas
forcément leur retraite à taux plein
donc vous faites automatiquement des
travailleurs les scénarios sont là
dessus très classique la réforme de
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
fait qu'il y a une baisse de la pension
moyenne on déclarez
oui oui de 300 euros en moyenne en
moyenne et la réforme de l'âge fait que
ça augmente le niveau de retraite c'est
la raison pour laquelle dans la
stabilité du système et pour l'équilibre
sur le long terme il faut faire un
mariage et de sinon c'est pas suffisant
la retraite ce n'est pas qu'un équilibre
budgétaire c'est aussi ça apporte ce que
ça dit pour la vie de nos concitoyens
quelqu'un qui a commencé à travailler à
19 ans ou quelqu'un qui a commencé à
travailler à 25 ans vous lui dites vous
allez partir tous les deux au même âge
vous vouloir fixer une retraite un
départ d'âge à la retraite à 64 ans
de dispositifs
uniquement sur la durée de cotisation
parce que comme ça vous êtes plus juste
vis-à-vis de la personne qui est partie
à 19 ans parce que les gens partiront
plus tôt si vous restez un âge légal ils
vont dire ben je pars à la Lège les gars
je ne pars pas l'âge du temps plein
d'utoplin heure actuellement les gens
pour le taux plein c'est important parce
que déjà il faut que la retraite elle
soit conséquente les difficultés donc si
vous ne partez pas là vous si vous n'en
citez pas si vous n'incitez pas les gens
à travers cette mesure d'âge
suffisamment quand même
conscient du niveau de retraite pour
partir à taux plein s'il le souhaite
au-delà de 60 ans après c'est pas la
même chose pour les taux plein et quand
on calcule la retraite c'est ce que vous
touchez à ce jour-là la durée moyenne
des retraites une vingtaine d'années la
moyenne avec toutes les difficultés
qu'on connaît mais on sait très bien
qu'il y a pas la revalorisation qui suit
donc où vous avez l'impression quand
vous prenez votre retraite que vous êtes
à peu près un niveau moyen par rapport à
vous dites ça va suffire sauf que 10 15
ans après ça suffit et vous faites des
personnes qui connaissent des
difficultés c'est quand même redoutable
je trouve comme système qui a commencé à
travailler à 19 ans vous allez partir à
64 ans quelqu'un qui a travaillé
commençait à travailler à 25 ans parce
qu'il a fait des études qui a un salaire
plus élevé vous lui mettez le même âge
mais c'est
mais oui au 19 ans 25 ans
de retraite anticipée pour carrière
longue vous l'ajuster en fonction c'est
quand même ça c'est ça existe ça
vous partez de la durée de cotisation
que vous introduisez de la pénibilité
parce que quand vous faites des métiers
du des publics vous avez une pénibilité
sur le port de chat qu'on parle du
travail des seniors c'est important et
donc ça c'est extrêmement important et
c'est deux leviers durée de cotisation
et pénibilité pour nous ce sont les deux
gens qui permettent d'avoir une réforme
des retraites juste et vous vous êtes
sur l'âge de départ à la retraite et ce
qui pour moi est injuste pour payer la
PIB de nnibilité il faut bien équilibrer
le système nous nous voulons une vraie
solidarité c'est pour ça que c'est pour
ça que il faut pouvoir la financer la
solidarité on est d'accord mais vous
pouvez ce sont des dépenses
supplémentaires
vous pouvez la finance là vous voulez la
financer sur les cotisations retraite la
pénibilité sans augmenter
vous pouvez imaginer une solidarité qui
soigne solidarité nationale par exemple
si on remet l'ISF ça peut financer la
solidarités
qui soit de justice sociale plutôt que
celle que vous proposez mais notre
système n'est pas injuste notre système
est un système qui permet justement de
maintenir les gens à l'employeur il y a
rien de pire et on avait
quelqu'un qui a commencé à travailler à
19 ans partira 64 ans et quelqu'un qui a
de commencer à travailler à 25 ans
partira 64 ans et celui qui a commencé
à 64 ans
justement ceux qui ont travaillé plus
tôt parle plutôt
en ligne de compte c'est la durée de
cotisations il y a la durée de
cotisation et l'âge minimum légal faut
trouver un équilibre mais vous partagez
le fait qu'il faut maintenir un certain
nombre de personnes
les emplois seniors en emploi
nous c'est notre philosophie en pensant
que plus il y a de personnes en emploi
plus ça crée des richesses plus on
enregistrer les jeunes c'est la raison
pour laquelle on est attaché à ce
maintien de l'emploi des seniors il faut
surtout pas qui quitte leur travail il
faut pas que ce soit la variable
d'ajustement il faut miser sur les
seniors c'est ce qu'on avait conclu et
avec des dispositifs qu'on peut
améliorer et je pense que vous en
partagez certains puisque vous aviez
essayé les contrats de générations c'est
notamment la retraite progressive
cumule emploi retraite qui permet de
travailler les trois jours et puis de
commencer à partir de jours à la
retraite par semaine qui est de la
flexibilité avant c'était pas possible
ce qui est pas de système informatique
aujourd'hui tout est informatisé on peut
avoir une
un système qui soit plus facilitant pour
l'ensemble des voilà c'est pour ça que
en jouant sur ces paramètres il y a
toujours une année qui peut être ou deux
années qui peuvent être plutôt une année
entre 63 et 64 ans qui pourraient
critique si on décale l'âge et c'est là
qu'il faut trouver que l'on propose
justement qui est des mesures
particulières pour qu'il y ait une
entrée en retraite progressive qu'on
arrête en France de liquider dit
définitivement sa retraite on part en
retraite et en fin de compte c'est fini
non il faut pouvoir la liquider de façon
intermédiaire continuer si possible
d'avoir un travail faire l'équilibre que
éventuellement des cotisations
supplémentaires qui rentrent en ligne de
compte puisque c'est pas pris
actuellement qui rentre en ligne de
compte dans ce cumulat et la question
qu'on peut vous poser puisque c'est vous
qui n'aviez pas accepté enfin la gauche
qui n'avait pas accepté à l'époque que
les cotisations
droit donne ouvre des droits en ce qui
concerne le cumul emploi retraite moi je
pense que c'est quelque chose sur lequel
il faut revenir vous aussi moi je suis
favorable à ce qui puisse y avoir un
cumul mais je redis je suis en défaveur
du report de l'âge légal de la
je préfère le préciser
mais là-dessus qu'il puisse y avoir un
aménagement pour augmenter parce
qu'effectivement on a 10 points de moins
en moyenne du taux de travail des
seniors par rapport au reste de l'Union
européenne oui facilement à peu près 10
mois voilà et donc le faciliter
favorable oui d'accord bah voilà voilà
je pense qu'il faut bien faire
comprendre à nos concitoyens que c'est
légitime que l'on est un maintien le
plus longtemps possible dans l'emploi et
ça permet en même temps de lutter contre
les troubles cognitifs etc ça aussi des
avantages en tout cas débat très
instructif ce serait bien que au
Parlement y est ce même genre d'échanges
parce que vous étiez passionnant tous